SEAN WOHLTMAN: Hi, I'm
Sean Wohltman.
I'm a geospatial scientist on
the Enterprise Team at Google.
JOSH LIVNI: Hi.
My name is Josh Livni.
I'm on the Developer Relations
Team for Maps.
So welcome, thank
you for coming.
This is Design Patterns for
Maps, Architecture.
If you guys are interested in UX
patterns, how to make your
map look amazing and beautiful
for the end user, you're in
the wrong session.
That would be the next session
coming up right after this,
Design Principles Maps.
So, here we're going to be
focusing on what happens
behind the scenes as you build
your application, some common
patterns we see developers come
across on all different
kinds of applications, and
best practices there.
SEAN WOHLTMAN: So last year,
when Hurricane Sandy made
landfall on the Eastern coast
of the United States, there
was a pretty interesting
application that was built.
It was called MapMill.
It was built by Schuyler Erle,
some crisis mappers, John
Crowley, Kate Chapman.
And the site was fairly
simple in it's design.
It showed images.
These images were collected,
over 35,000 of them, by the
Civil Air Patrol in
various states.
These are guys hanging out
inside of Blackhawks or
outside fixed wing airplanes,
taking pictures of what they
saw on the ground.
And they do that because these
are the first eyes on the
destruction there.
So they have all these thousands
of images, and what
they asked was the public to
come in, whether you were a
seasoned photo mode scientist,
or if you were a novice that
was just interested in
trying to help out.
And it was very simple, look
at the photo and rate it.
Is it light damage, moderate
damage, or would you say that
this is heavy damage?
And here this picture of
Seaside, New Jersey,
obviously, would be
heavy damage.
And the cool thing about it was
they took the aggregate of
all those votes and
created a grid.
And as soon as we saw this, we
saw an immense potential.
This was information that was
going to be really helpful for
first responders, and for
decision makers where to go
and deploy assets.
So we took this grid and we
deployed it to the Google
Crisis Map.
And in so doing, we almost
started to impact our server.
Because Schuyler was putting
out a geoJSON feed of this
entire grid and we, basically,
were going and scraping it to
put it into our servers,
on an update cycle.
And we handled all the caching
once it got our servers, but
that direct request, every
single time I was going to do
an update, was starting
to impact the main
purpose of that site.
So because Schuyler knows
what he's doing.
He's been doing GIS for
a long time and web
development for a long time.
He said, this is a
simple solution.
Let me dump this out as a cache,
periodically, and then
you can hit that cache and
not take down our site.
It's a good thing he did it
because the site, not just
through Crisis Maps but through
lots of other press
releases, became very popular.
A lot of people got involved
in this activity.
In fact, we said traffic
records, on the Crisis Map,
for the amount of traffic coming
in, with people in the
Northeast wondering what was
going on, how were their
homes, were homes gone?
And so, it's a good thing, that
simple little change, of
rather than having a dynamic
request for millions of
people, to having a simple
cache, that we then cached for
them made all the difference.
JOSH LIVNI: Yeah, so why would
you care about this?
You might be thinking your
application is not going to
necessarily be front page of
reddit, hopefully it is, or on
our Crisis Map feature there.
There's all kinds of
applications though that the
same set of principles
applies.
SEAN WOHLTMAN: That's right, I
mean what if you were building
a really important local crime
map and you wanted to get that
information out there because
it's important to people in
your community.
JOSH LIVNI: Yeah, or a totally
different real estate site.
We talked about some
of these last year.
Where you've got lots of dynamic
data updating, to tons
of people visiting on lots
of different platforms.
SEAN WOHLTMAN: Or what if you
have an incredibly popular
game like "Ingress." And you've
got millions of spatial
points of interest that you're
trying to keep track of, and
how people interact with them.
JOSH LIVNI: Yup, or perhaps,
you're a local municipality
trying to put out some
spatial data.
It's relatively static, to a
relatively small number of
people but you need to make sure
it's interactive in the
appropriate way.
SEAN WOHLTMAN: Or you're relying
on a very dynamic
feed, like an earthquake feed.
And you have different
visualizations that people can
come and customize, to try to
make a map that makes the most
sense to them.
JOSH LIVNI: Or a super immersive
application, where
you're really taking advantage
of some of the data, and
imagery, and terrain matches
that we have, to really get
people in and add a little bit
of your own magic on top.
SEAN WOHLTMAN: So there's
various tools that you might
do for this.
And there's various options here
at Google that you can
use to make these applications
work.
You can use the Google Maps API
and just push data into
the client.
JOSH LIVNI: Yup, so a little
bit of JavaScript there or
perhaps some KML?
Maybe you're writing
your own KML?
Maybe you're using it as it
transport across different
types of interoperable
GeoServers.
SEAN WOHLTMAN: Or maybe you have
a little application that
you're hosting on Drive that
spits out geoJSON.
Or you're pulling geoJSON feeds,
like we were, from an
external site.
JOSH LIVNI: So, we have a ton of
different ways and services
that help you build mapping
applications.
And we see developers,
oftentimes, pick and choose a
few different tools and run
into similar problems.
And what we want to do is show
you, through a few different
stories we'll get to in a
minute, some common patterns
we've seen that might help you
think about, in advance, what
might affect your application
as it grows.
So before we get into that
though, I wanted to highlight
something that Brian mentioned
on stage earlier today, which
is our Maps Engine platform.
So this is pretty cool.
I'm not sure if all of
you have the chance
to play with it.
What we have here is the Maps
Engine layer in Maps API.
Just loading some different
layers.
I loaded parcels from
San Francisco and
trees from San Francisco.
And you can go ahead
and scroll around
and click on them.
And the thing I want to mention,
just upfront--
we'll talk about some more
of the stuff later--
is that all of you are welcome,
now to go ahead and
get an account on Maps Engine.
You can head over to the
Sandbox, the Google Maps
Sandbox right after
this. talk.
Give us your email and you'll
within a few minutes be signed
up to a test account, where you
can play around with this.
So throughout this session we
are referring to some of the
things that, hopefully, you
guys will be playing
with in a few hours.
SEAN WOHLTMAN: And if you want
to know more about it, there's
also a session tomorrow called
"Our Maps Your Business." And
so if you want to get a more
in-depth look into Google Maps
Engine than we're going to do
today, I highly suggest
attending that session.
JOSH LIVNI: Yeah.
OK, so as we mentioned,
there's a
lot of common patterns.
You look at all different
kinds of applications--
and we just showed a small
subset of the kind you might
be building on the previous
animation--
and we see very similar
patterns.
So we're going to go ahead
and start out with some
crowdsourcing example to
show you what we mean.
SEAN WOHLTMAN: So also during
Hurricane Sandy, we had
another very popular layer that
made its way onto the
Crisis Map.
Because of the extent of damage
to trees and power
lines that were down, a lot of
the residents had no power for
days and weeks on end.
So a lot of folks actually did
prepare, did have generators.
And there was, all of a sudden,
a 1970s gas shortage
inside of a New Jersey
and New York.
So, some enterprising young
students decided, hey, why
don't we get people, feet on the
ground, to try to make a
map of this.
So, let's define
a problem here.
All right, we need to map which
gas stations have gas.
That's a fairly simple
problem statement.
How do you go about
approaching that?
So you might think, well,
let's go ahead
and create a forum.
We'll get a forum out there.
What's the name of
the gas station?
What's the address?
Is there gas available?
And you're probably going to
host that forum somewhere on
the internet.
And then the idea is that you're
going to make this as
viral as possible.
Hopefully get some
press behind it.
And people are going to come
in and submit that type of
information.
But you can't really
trust everybody.
There's most of the times
people try to
do good during crisis.
But there's always going to
somebody that's going to come
in there and troll.
So, you're going to have some
sort of moderation capability
in there as well.
Somebody that can be able
to approve things.
Somebody you trust, that's been
working on the project
for a while and you trust
their opinion.
And then you have to be able
to make this spatial.
So you're going to want to
export that to some sort of
format, whether it's KML, or
geoJSON, or whatever the
geo-flavor du jour is.
And then, like we saw with
Schuyler, you really want to
make sure that if you have a
database or if you have some
service that's generating
these feeds, that you're
caching out the results,
right?
You don't want people hitting
your live service.
And then, and only then, once
you're up and set up and
running, that's when you want
to put this data on a map.
JOSH LIVNI: Right.
So, we'll make a brief segue
here into something we see
happen a lot, when people start
collecting information
that's spatially related.
You come up with this type of
forum we mentioned earlier.
You've got all the information
you think you need; the
address; even the latitude,
longitude.
I've seen forms out there, just
like this in the wild.
And I just want to say that this
is not a very good form.
So part of best practices for
your architecture, is taking
advantage of other people's
architecture.
So this took me two or three
minutes to modify this form,
that I created in Google
Spreadsheets under the form,
and added an interactive map
and a little drop down.
So if I'm looking for a gas
station, say Exxon and it'll
pop it right up.
And this is just cut and paste
code, directly from our
example, super easy.
And if I happen to know the
gas station's there, I can
kind of drag it over and update
the latitude, longitude.
Those fields should be hidden.
Users should never
know about that.
Anyway, you go ahead.
You say there's gas there.
You submit the form.
And what you should see, there
it is, is the crowdsourced
information coming into
your spreadsheet.
And we've got an extra column
for confirmed, where a smaller
select group of people
can modify that.
Now, once you're at this
stage you have a
whole bunch of data.
We want to get it out
onto the map.
This is pretty easy.
The form took just a few
minutes to create.
I could go here to tools
and use Apps Script.
Now, if you're interested in
creating really amazing forms
with really powerful Apps Script
integration, you just
missed a talk about that.
But you can catch it on video.
I think they're all going live
in the next day or two.
So the talk for that is called
Forms, Use Apps Script to
Create Dynamic Forms.
So, pretty cool talk where they
go over the power of Apps
Script, and all the kinds
of things you could do.
For example, if something new
comes in, you could send that
data to a different API or
service that you have to run
some computations in it.
And all kinds of dynamic
interaction you can do with
Apps Script.
The easiest way to go
from here is just a
File, Publish to Web.
And then you get the power
of the spreadsheets API.
The data comes out.
A RESTful request that
you can make.
Make it public.
People can hit that feed.
It scales reasonably well.
There's a little extra work
though involved in sort of
transforming that data feed in
XML or JSON to something more
map friendly.
Because this will not
necessarily have that in mind.
So keep in mind those tradeoffs,
if you're just
going this really simple way.
And also keep in mind the
tradeoff of, this is not
designed for tens of thousands
of points.
Of course, spreadsheets
can handle that.
It's too much data to send over
the wire to the client,
on all these dynamic requests.
So, a super simple way to
get up and running.
Just think about the way you're
bring the data in and
how you want to publish
it out.
Oh yeah, and then a lot of
people, when we mention
scalability, they think
immediately QPS.
What is the queries
per second.
I don't know how many of you
have noticed the little
sensors we have around
Google I/0.
Hopefully, you guys
have seen that.
We have hundreds of those.
There's one right on stage,
tracking me as I talk.
And tracking you, if
you walk by it.
And tracking five or six other
different things, including
temperature and all
kinds of readings.
There's a great talk on that,
the Data Sensing Labs,
tomorrow evening.
Check out the architecture
there.
My point is here, we have
a whole bunch of data.
This is also crowdsourcing.
The issue here isn't tons of
people hitting the site, but
rather tons of data.
Every few seconds they are
sending a variety of different
signals back to a server.
With upwards of the thousands
of these sensors, you're
talking tens, hundreds of
millions of data points, over
the course of days or weeks.
So that's a lot of data
and it's more
than most people have.
It kind of gets in the
realm of big data.
And so, think about that.
If you're going to have a big
data set, that maybe the
standard tools that you're using
for crowdsourcing, or
even maps, aren't
going to apply.
Now, luckily, it turns out
almost nobody has big data.
Everyone wishes they did and big
data conferences are fun,
but when it comes to mapping
and GIS, most people have
medium-sized data.
SEAN WOHLTMAN: So what do we
mean by medium-sized data?
This is a class of data, like
Josh said, that most people
actually have.
This is the data that's too big
to send the browser, but
not quite big data.
We're talking greater than 5
megs, probably up to a couple
million rows at max.
So what are the strategies and
what are the patterns are you
want to employ when you're
dealing with
this type of data?
This is important since it
is what most of you have.
So, if you have a small area
in San Francisco, you could
probably get away with pushing
all the geometries in the
Google Maps API and actually
drawing them
as an overlay here.
But what if you wanted to take
that layer and push it out to
all of San Francisco?
We're now talking about a couple
hundred megabyte file
that you have to be able to try
to push into the client.
And that's not going to be a
happy day for anybody, right?
Because you want to
keep that density.
You want to make that map
interactive and have all the
data there.
So what's the easiest
strategy?
Well, it's nothing
really novel.
What you really want to employ
is take that data and then you
want to break it up
into a server-side
rendering of that data.
You want to be able to just make
a simple overlay of 256
by 256 pixels.
But it's not just a
rasterization process.
Because people are going to
expect that these parcels are
interactive.
So you have to have a strategy
for being able to do some sort
of interaction.
Whether that means you're using
some sort of an UTF grid
or using some other technology,
that you're making
that click actually respond
and get data back.
So if we take a look at the
diagram from the architecture
standpoint, it's not too
different from the
crowdsource.
You've got one or maybe a couple
people collaborating on
uploading a big data set.
You probably still have
some moderation piece.
If you're a county and you're
doing a tax assessment, and
you're going out and you're
changing polygons, you need to
have some sort of moderation
piece.
But then you need to have the
server-side rendering piece
that's going to take that vector
data, rasterize it and
also keep track of the
[? action ?] data for you.
Again, you're going to
want to have a cache.
The nice thing about having
static tiles is there's kind
of cache built into that,
in the sense that the
tiles are the cache.
But you also want to make
sure that it's load
balanced, of course.
If this becomes a very popular
site, where your map goes
viral, you're going to want to
make sure that you could
handle the traffic
load for it.
And then you publish
it out to the map.
JOSH LIVNI: Yeah, so I saw this
really innovative site
and it's almost sad that
it's innovative.
It's a GIS portal for the
City of Palo Alto.
I think they launched about
a month or two ago.
And it kind of stood out to me
because I go to a lot of GIS
data portals.
And it's usually, after going
through some click-agreement,
just a list of downloads.
Hopefully, in a format that
your standard GIS
software can read.
Often not.
And so you have no idea what the
data is until you download
it and put it into some
sort of GIS system.
What I liked about the site, in
particular, is you can kind
of scroll down, play
with the map.
Click on things actually
directly.
See that you can have some
fairly complex data.
Here's some land use
data, for example.
It looks pretty good.
You have an immediate
idea of what it is,
before you jump in.
And then potentially choose to
download or otherwise play
with the data.
Pretty cool.
So, let's go ahead and see how
you might go about building
that type of application, and
just a simple way to do it.
So, just as we walked you
through it in the crowdsource
example using Google
Spreadsheets.
We'll talk about our Maps
Engine platform here.
So again, you guys can get some
test accounts by going
the Sandbox, if you haven't
signed up already.
Let's go ahead and dive in.
So the first thing you're going
to do is you're going to
have some data, hopefully.
It could be a KML.
It could be a shape
file, a variety of
other formats are supported.
You can upload those
files individually.
Or what I like to do is click
the Upload button
and choose a folder.
And that folder could just
be full of all different
kinds of GIS data.
And then you just batch upload
it all with one click.
So you've uploaded what
we call data sources.
Now you want to make a map.
And we do that by creating
what we call a layer.
And that is, basically,
some styles
associated with your data.
So we have some pretty
nice styling
widgets here on the left.
You can go ahead and set
filters, based on zoom level
or attributes.
So if I want to style all the
parcels that are on a certain
type of street, [INAUDIBLE]
will drop down auto-populated
based on your data.
We won't go into
that too much.
The next point here is you can
also upload custom icons.
So, I brought in some trees
earlier, as an example.
We have a whole bunch
of nice icons.
But if you don't like them, you
can upload your own icons
according to your brand or
whatever icons you like, and
style with those.
And then the other key piece
here that it adds is really
robust and simple ways to
share the data out.
So it uses the exact same
sharing dialogue you might be
familiar with from
Google Docs, and
Spreadsheets, and so forth.
Where you just select the people
that have access to the
data, access to the published
or unpublished versions.
And I won't get into that
too much now either.
But it's a kind of
a key principle.
It's kind of that
moderation flow.
You can have a public person
that everyone sees.
And then some along the stages
of creating layers maps.
Versions that only people that
you trust or within your
organization can play with.
So, the most exciting thing that
I want to talk about is
our relatively new API, which we
made public just last week.
So I'm not sure many of you have
had a chance to check out
the documentation.
We'll point out a
couple things.
Those of you who are familiar
with geoJSON
might recognize it.
That's the format that we spit
out by default, if you make a
query for features
in your data set.
So that's kind of nice.
It's an interoperable standard
with lots of other software.
And then what can you
do with that?
So let's take a look at
some of the other
end points the API.
To walk you through some of the
things that the API offers
I put together this pretty
straightforward application.
If you could see the URL, and
I'm sure you can't, the URL is
googlemaps.github.io.
So, if you go to GitHub and
look at our Google Maps
account, you'll see a project
under there called Galley.
This is the Galley
application.
It basically is a proof of
concept for working with the
Maps Engine API.
So I'm going to go ahead
and authorize it.
What's nice about this, it's
using the GitHub pages, is
there's no server in
the background.
I use the JavaScript OAuth
library to authenticate in.
So that's kind of nice.
You can build just a straight
web app, use OAuth,
authenticate in securely, and
you have access to all the
stuff that users should
have access to.
In this case, I have access to
two projects; signed up for
one of those test accounts, so
I have access to that; and I
have access to my Josh
Livni account.
We have access to all of the
data and end points.
Some of the things I mentioned
before are
the maps, the layers.
I can render the layers if I
click, for example, on the
trees and zoom in.
You should be able to see all of
the trees that we rendered
according to the styles
that we have.
We also have access
to the tables.
This is kind of your
data sources.
Just going to give an example
of how we can
interact with those.
So I downloaded the parks from
City of West Sacramento.
And I'm going to go ahead and
zoom-in to some parks here.
Click on this park and I can
just go ahead and edit things.
And the way this
is doing this--
I'll get rid of that exclamation
mark I added
earlier, send it back
to the server.
And it makes a POST, a
RESTful interface.
And now that data is live.
So the next people who view the
published maps are going
to be able to see my updates.
Oh, yeah.
Let's see some satellite data.
And I can also go ahead and
edit the geometries.
It's a very simple tool.
Just using the Maps API geometry
editing, I can go
ahead and drag this around.
Add a little park space.
It's probably not legal.
Hit Save.
And there we go.
Again, posted back.
So this is a simple way to play
with the application.
Feel free to check out
the code on GitHub.
I tried to document it nicely.
So you get an idea of how we're
interacting with the
API, how you can build
similar applications.
You could imagine, for example,
that crowdsourcing
app, it starts to need
a little bit more
robustness to it.
You could go ahead use Apps
Script to push the data to
Maps Engine on certain things
occurring in the database,
like things got confirmed.
And now you can render those
out, again, like Brian
mentioned earlier, using the
same power that we have behind
Google Maps itself.
So all of this data is sent out
to all of our data center
super duper fast.
Rendering using the same
technology we use to render
the base map.
So there's a great way
to publish your apps.
SEAN WOHLTMAN: How many lines
of code, is that?
JOSH LIVNI: The grand total?
It's about 600 lines of code,
I think, including the
documentations.
It's a super simple app.
I think Twitter Bootstrap helped
me out a little bit.
As did, obviously, the OOP
JavaScript library.
I didn't have to pay attention
to UI or authentication.
But it's really, really
simple to build an
application like this.
So, if you need a map editing
tool, feel free to
fork it and have fun.
Oh yes, thank you Sean.
So, we also have assets.
Assets are what we call
all the stuff you
put into Maps Engine.
So it includes--
if you scroll down the
left hand panel--
all of our tables, and
maps, and so forth.
But also a whole bunch
of other stuff
over on the East Coast.
Maybe, Sean, you could tell us
a little bit more about what
those things are.
SEAN WOHLTMAN: Yeah, so the nice
thing about Maps Engine
is it's not just about vector
data that we've
been talking about.
And that's where we're going to
pick up our story with the
next type of data that you might
be coming across, which
would be imagery.
So imagery, we're probably
familiar with it.
Here's a shot of us here in the
Moscone Center, nice 15
centimeter resolution imagery.
But it's not just photographs.
It can also be charts.
You might have charting data,
like this NOAA RNC of Oahu.
And the same strategy applies
that we talked about with the
medium-sized data.
This is where Google Maps got
its start, like Brian
mentioned, is actually doing
the tiling and creating a
static tile cache.
So the same principle applies.
You need to have some server in
place that's going to take
that image, chop it up into 256
by 256 pixel images, and
then serve them out.
Now, it's really simple once
you have those tiles, to
overlay them with the
Google Maps API.
So if I have a Maps API site, I
can just make sure that the
tiles are exported into the
web Mercator, which is a
standard for all slippy maps.
This got a EPSG code of 3785.
And then if I want to play with
the 3D, I want to make
sure that I also want to
put out tiles in the
plaque array or 4356.
In this case, this is really
nice because I've got the
bathymetry from Google Earth.
And I'm overlaying this
nautical chart
with all these soundings.
And the soundings are lining
up under water.
So this is an option.
If you're going to serve a 3D
application, you want to make
sure that you have tiles
in that format as well.
So, just to review you've
got your image.
You've got some sort of server
running a tile rendering.
Once again, your cache is kind
of already built for you
because it is static tiles.
But you do have to think about
if you're going to put it out
to two different projections.
There are a couple of
categories, I would say, and
different patterns that evolve
when you're taking a look at
what the use case of
the imagery is.
And the first one that I want to
talk about is what I would
call fast response imagery.
This could be-- if you followed
Public Laboratory and
funded this Kickstarter--
a great project where you take a
cellphone or camera, a point
and shoot camera, and tie it
from a weather balloon.
Or you go and follow DIY Drones
and build your own
drone and put and Android
phone there.
And a little Arduino
to pilot it.
Or it could be actually formal
imagery, such as NOAA.
NOAA goes those out and
collects imagery after
hurricanes.
And they actually fly with
really nice commercial cameras
in real planes.
But the key here is if it's
fast response imagery, it
needs to be fast, right?
Time is of the essence.
Here's an example from
Hurricane Sandy.
This is Mantoloking,
New Jersey.
This is the first eyes on
that we had of the area.
And it's pretty dramatic if
you take a look at what
Mantoloking looked
like before.
See the bridge coming into
these beautiful homes,
beautiful little beach town.
And then after Sandy
rolled through, the
dramatic change there.
We have all of a sudden, a new
natural-made inlet and houses
have been wiped out.
Josh is going to tell us a
little bit about one strategy
that we could use to
get that imagery
out as fast as possible.
JOSH LIVNI: Yeah, again, so
we'll take this super simple
case first.
You have a little
bit of imagery.
You want to get it out to people
as quickly as possible.
There's tons are proprietary
and open source tools and
workflows available for this.
I'm going to show you one
example using the GDAL Library
and Google Compute Engine.
Now, I'm not sure if you noticed
any of the talks from
the cloud track this morning,
but Google Compute Engine, I
believe, is available
to everyone tonight.
And also they've announced a
bunch of other great stuff,
like [? sub-hour ?] billing,
and you can boot up lost
instances, and turn it down
as needed, and so forth.
So the way to get access to
this is you go to the
Developer console, which is the
same place you might, for
example, get an API key
for Google Maps.
You go to your Services
tab and just enable
Google Compute Engine.
So once you've done that, you'll
see a Google Compute
Engine logo.
You can go ahead and
click on that.
Go to the Instances tab.
And then there's a variety
of options.
I like to just choose a standard
Ubuntu instance.
Don't worry too much about the
other parameters, booted up.
We're going to show you
how easy this is.
So you boot up the server.
You SSH into this this
virtual server that
runs in our data centers.
And then you just run two
command lines to get up going
with GIS in our server.
Install Apache2, so that I can
have web requests coming in.
We're going to serve
out some tiles.
And then go ahead and install
UbuntuGIS, which installs a
whole bunch of software,
including this GDAL Library.
After we've run those we're
going to go ahead and download
some imagery data.
And then we're going to use
that GDAL tiles library.
Which is a little Python script,
basically, that will
mosaic that data together.
And create all of the
appropriate tiles in all the
appropriate projections
for you.
So, it took about two minutes,
I think, for the data we
downloaded.
And rather than waiting two
minutes, we made a video.
I think it just finished.
So that was it.
Download the data, created
some tiles, done.
Now we have the tiles in a
folder, and let's take a look
at the results.
SEAN WOHLTMAN: Great, so
the results of that.
We have a nice little embedded
Google Maps V3 API site here.
And I can zoom-in to that area
that looked really damaged.
And I have a nice little custom
overlay here, so I can
do a little transparency
slider.
And you can just really start to
see the total destruction.
Now getting this out to people,
especially people
whose homes those were, first
responders and rescue folks
coming into the area,
is critical.
So this is a perfectly fine way
to address a small area,
get that data out there
as quick as possible
with minimum friction.
As long as you understand a
little bit about the GIS tools
behind the scenes.
But, what if it's not
a small area?
What if it's a really
big area.
America, the United States
is a pretty big area.
It's about eight million square
kilometers and what if
you wanted to do imagery
on that scale?
And what if it was fairly
high resolution?
I'm not talking high resolution
like we showed
earlier, 15 centimeters.
But the USDA NAIP program, every
three years basically,
recovers the United States
in one meter imagery.
So you can take a look at
the Moscone Center here.
Obviously, it's not going
to be totally
exciting in urban areas.
But it's not really designed
for urban areas.
It's really designed to go out
and survey agriculture.
They fly it in four bands,
so they can also do some
photogrammetery telling
the different crops
that are being grown.
So, this imagery, if you had
it for the entire United
States, which we do, for the
past three years would be
about 80 terabytes of imagery.
So my first problem is now I
need to upload 80 terabytes of
imagery somewhere.
And then, it's not just
that imagery.
Now, I actually we need
to make tiles with it.
So take that same three
years of data, I'm
going to tile it out.
It comes to about 1.3
billion tiles that I
need to write to disk.
And that in itself is about
another 30 terabytes.
So, now I've got to worry about
how many disks I need,
how much CPU and RAM I need to
spin up, how long this is
going to take.
And there are a lot of really
smart people working on how to
do this with big map
reduce processes.
My recommendation being not
try to reinvent the wheel.
So we took all this and put it
into Google Maps Engine.
And we blended and served
redundantly over thousands of
cores in a few hours.
And when I say we served it
redundantly, we're writing
this to multiple data centers
at once, for you with Google
Maps Engine.
So we're actually taking
all that data.
We only tile it out to not
just one data center, but
across multiple data centers.
And it's ready in a few hours.
So take a look at a quick
preview of this.
Here we have a 2D map.
And this is the default map that
you would get with Google
Maps Engine.
This is built for you.
This is the Google Maps view.
And you can come in and see it's
just as performing as the
underlying tiles
that are there.
The one meter can go back
and forth, on and off.
And the nice thing about Google
Maps Engine, if you
remember I brought up before
that I wanted to
serve both 2D and 3D.
Google Maps Engine doesn't
charging the overhead for also
doing that in 3d as well.
So you get a lot of bang for
your buck, running on the same
servers that are running the
rest of Google properties.
And there's another thing that
we should talk about as well.
There's a security piece here.
I could share that map.
I can make it private.
Maybe it's licensed data.
Maybe I can't put it out
to the entire public.
So I have the security
things that we
talked about with Josh.
But we've only talked about,
so far, about putting this
data out onto Google properties,
Google Maps and
Google Earth.
And if you work with
anybody the GIS
community, they loved it.
It's nice, but they also want to
be able to use it in their
analytic applications.
So if you were going to do this
yourself you now have to
think about how am I
going to implement
things like OGC standards.
How am I going to put
out a WMS feed?
Am I going to have to
have the overhead of
returning WMS requests?
Google Maps Engine does take
care of that for you.
And so you can put it out into
OGC compliant feeds that can
work with other applications,
outside
of the Google framework.
JOSH LIVNI: Thanks, John.
Yes, so hopefully you can
see that even from a
little bit of data--
maybe it's vector data you're
crowdsourcing, maybe it's a
little bit of imagery, many of
the same things apply-- if you
just have to serve it up a few
people, it's static, you're
not worried about a huge influx
of data or dynamic
requests taking you down, then
there's a ton of tools and
options out there.
As people start adding
complexity--
and this is inevitable for most
popular applications--
and they need to think about
things like the moderation
piece, the simple sharing piece,
the permissions, and so
forth, the different
projections, the OGC
standards, make sure that you're
using a framework and
thinking about that
in advance.
So when you do get popular one
day and someone starts
slamming you, you have
a cache ready.
When someone says, we need to
take care some moderation
issues, you have a method
in place to do that.
So, hopefully, we showed you
through some different stories
that many of the same
pattern arise.
We tried really hard to put out
some software that makes
this as easy as possible
for you guys.
Hopefully, you go out and try
some of that software,
including Google Maps Engine.
Let us know you think.
And also let us know if you
have any questions.
I think we have about
10 minutes.
Yeah, thank you very much.
If you do have questions, please
come up to the mics.
And speak into the mics
and we'll do our best.
AUDIENCE: Hello,
my name's Pat.
I work for a high tech
agriculture firm based in Des
Moines, Iowa.
And I know that was
interesting.
SEAN WOHLTMAN: Not a plant.
AUDIENCE: We have a problem.
And that is that a lot of people
in the agricultural
industry live and work in areas
where they don't have
good access to the internet.
And so, I'm curious if you
have any suggestions for
patterns and practices that
would help people when they're
wanting to look at map data,
and they do not have an
internet connection?
SEAN WOHLTMAN: Yes, in fact we
have a session tomorrow.
[? Sean Maday ?]
and [? Harsh Bhatnagar ?]
are doing, basically, what
happens when you have to go
off the grid.
I'd highly recommend taking
a look at that.
There's commercial applications,
but there's also
grants that we do that,
basically, allow cutting from
the Google Maps Engine
platforms.
And you can actually take
portables of the
maps that you create.
And take them with you in a
portable cache that you could
run on a PC, Mac,
or Linux server.
AUDIENCE: I want to question
using Google Maps data.
Can you take the different
scenarios
for the Bermuda Triangle.
Because people who go there,
they don't come back, I heard.
Right?
So Bermuda triangle.
SEAN WOHLTMAN: I'm sorry.
AUDIENCE: There's something
called Bermuda triangle,
JOSH LIVNI: Oh the
Ber-- yeah, sure.
AUDIENCE: So, where if a ship
goes, it doesn't come back.
Or if people going, they
won't come back.
So maybe using this Maps data
you can find out what is the
geographical forces, which is
making it so dangerous.
And get some conclusion.
That's an interesting idea.
I'm, actually, surprised
somebody hasn't made some cool
mashups of--
I'm sure the satellites
have lots of imagery.
SEAN WOHLTMAN: But actually
there's a talk tomorrow.
The AIS talk--
JOSH LIVNI: Setting
us up, too.
SEAN WOHLTMAN: --about
tracking all the
ships in the world.
And using bit query and Google
Maps on doing that.
JOSH LIVNI: Good call.
Yeah, in fact we have a few--
AUDIENCE: Find out what
is happening there.
There is much energy,
wind energy.
So they can also use that wind
energy for this Google
[INAUDIBLE]
and then you can put a [?
Cart ?] there and see
what is happening.
JOSH LIVNI: It's a
good question.
Yeah, I'm certainly no
expert on ship data.
But we happen to have some
experts on ship data giving
talks at different tracks.
So check out the descriptions.
I think we have like
two or three talks.
And these guys really know about
ships and where they go.
And we're going to be showing
that, so that's a better
question for someone there.
AUDIENCE: -- there is so much
of energy there, wind energy
there, you know.
So all that energy you
could use it for
something else right?
maybe using those analytics and
the data of Google Maps
you could use
[? it for something. ?]
SEAN WOHLTMAN: Very possibly.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi, you kind of
wowed me with the forms
example and the map
to the side.
You said that it was pretty
easy produce, but my
experience with forms is
it's quite limiting.
And I was just curious if you
go into a little bit of the
details on that?
I mean, did you to create a
sidebar with the map and
that's how you got it to record
lat, longs in the form?
JOSH LIVNI: Sure, the way that
I made that form was what I'd
call the old school way,
that I don't recommend.
But what I did is I
created the form
using the forms widget.
You hit forms and
spreadsheets.
And now of course, you could
create easily your own form.
If you have an open source, CMS,
Django based or something
to create a web form.
It's just a web form.
You're trying to get
it somewhere.
But in any case, what I did
is I modified the Google
Spreadsheets form to have
all the fields I needed.
Then I downloaded it.
And then I opened up the HTML
and I added a tiny bit of
JavaScript to attach
the fields.
Took me about five minutes.
Went into our examples for auto
complete, and I just cut
and pasted some code, changed
the input field.
It's done.
So it was pretty easy.
But, as I mentioned, there was a
talk that was, I think, just
last session, where they go over
how to do that correctly.
So Apps Script is super powerful
and you can do all
kinds of dynamic things
with the forms now.
And so, that talk will be on
video and that would be a
better way to approach
the problem.
SEAN WOHLTMAN: But we will also
have this entire talk
posted, so you'll have the
slides to go in and take a
look at the source, as well.
JOSH LIVNI: Yep.
I'm scared now.
AUDIENCE: Hi, I'm Andy.
I work for a company that
provides solutions that
overlay map data on top
of Google Maps.
And one question I had was,
in your best practices
recommended, you talked about
meshing up large imagery in
tiles and serving that out.
But I also heard, in the keynote
this morning, about
the vector maps and how that's
the way of the future.
So what do you recommend
best practices on
serving up vector maps?
SEAN WOHLTMAN: So, I mean, one
thing to say is that when you
have imagery, unless somebody
has a really amazing
algorithm, that that's
not going to get
vectorized any time soon.
I think we're still going
to be in that
world for a long time.
But yeah, do you want
to take the vector--
JOSH LIVNI: Sure, yeah.
So, today we try to serve out
the tiles in the most
appropriate format.
So, the hope is you upload
your data vector, in this
case, to Google Maps Engine.
And we'll serve it out
appropriately.
If one day it turns out that the
appropriate way to serve
that data is in vectors,
that's the way
it'll be served out.
So, the idea is you don't have
to concern yourself with that.
Now, there are some talks, I
think [? Brandon Candy ?]
is giving a talk on some amazing
things you can do with
WebGL in creating your own
vector data that gets
displayed on the clients.
And that's a good
talk to go to.
I think it's called HTMl
5 A Love Affair
and Maps a Love Affair.
And there's a bunch of ways
you can do it yourself.
But yeah, obviously we have
a lot of technology and we
believe that is a really
great way to go.
And we'll make sure that your
data is served up when it
makes sense, in the right way.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
JOSH LIVNI: No problem.
AUDIENCE: Good day, I
have one question.
Please tell me, I want
to keep a road graph.
Can I keep a road graph by
tools, by storage if I have
maybe 10,000 or 100,000 vertices
is in my graph.
And I need in calculation maybe,
brought in compilation
maybe by the extra algorithm
or another.
Or I must keep it separate.
Mainly vertices on my server
for calculation and some
vertices for visualization
by your Maps Engine.
So what about performance?
SEAN WOHLTMAN: Yes, so right now
doing Dijkstra or A-Star
or anything like that over
a vector network is not
something that Maps
Engine does.
But when we talked about Compute
Engine, you should
think about that as
a possibility.
To be able to run the
traditional PostGIS or
pgRouting types of applications
in the database
in appropriate form, until we
can offer that as a direct
offering in Google
Maps Engine.
AUDIENCE: But if people create
some vertices of raw graph by
themselves then we have a
[INAUDIBLE] or an other site.
Can we use your storage as a
local cache, as front end
server for our backends, in
order to send it backend?
JOSH LIVNI: Yeah, so the general
pattern there is, if
you would like us to render
it out, we have the API.
So I showed a really simple
example of editing some
geometries, but, of course,
you can batch post a whole
bunch of features into an
existing table, modify, or
delete them.
So, if you need to do some type
of synchronization or
adding new things to data that's
in Google Maps Engine,
you can do that using the API.
AUDIENCE: Sorry, do we need an
Engine server for balancing
between my backend
and your storage?
JOSH LIVNI: I'm not
sure I understood.
SEAN WOHLTMAN: You're asking
how to connect between your
backend database, to what
it would be in ours.
AUDIENCE: I don't know about
average number of requests to
your storage?
What about it?
JOSH LIVNI: You mean if you're
doing like a whole bunch of
requests, very frequently,
what are our limits?
So, we have a few different
limits.
I think right now, if you
purchase Google Maps Engine--
I'm not sure exactly offhand
what the queries per second is
that you can post and get.
It's pretty high and I think
you can, as many of our
offerings, purchase more
quota as you need.
I'm not sure what it is
offhand, by default.
But it should be plenty.
I mean it's many a second.
And you can batch post a large
number of features that once.
So I think it should suffice.
SEAN WOHLTMAN: If there is a
use case you really want to
dig down into, please
come by the Sandbox.
JOSH LIVNI: Yeah, we can talk
a little more detail,
something specific.
AUDIENCE: Quick question, in
your imagery example, how was
that 30 terabytes of
data delivered?
SEAN WOHLTMAN: How
is it delivered?
As tiles.
AUDIENCE: I'm sorry, delivered
to the Google App Engine.
SEAN WOHLTMAN: Oh, how do
we upload the initial?
AUDIENCE: How do the--
Yeah.
SEAN WOHLTMAN: OK, so there's
a technology that Google has
called Xenon.
Which, like Josh said, there's
one way in which you could sit
there and try to bulk
upload of all that.
For the 80 terabyte source,
you probably
don't want to do that.
Xenon is a technology that
Google uses to monitor remote
web servers, where we have a lot
of partners, such as VEVO
that puts out a lot
of music videos.
And we monitor either a http or
a ftp site, where we will
actually pull that data across
data center to data center.
And we can ingest that for you
into a particular account.
So, it needs to be on
a server somewhere.
Or, if it's a really big
delivery like that, we can
actually have customer
agreements through some of our
partners that will help get
that data online for you.
Because, yes, getting a large
amount of data into the cloud
is a barrier to entry.
JOSH LIVNI: OK, well thank you
guys very much for coming.
Sean and I will be in the Google
Maps Sandbox for the
next hour or so.
Look forward to chatting
with you guys.
SEAN WOHLTMAN: Thank you.